ich weiß wer ich bin wenn wir mit ihnen
fertig sind werden sie nicht mehr david
webseite besonderheit dieser figur es
eben die das spitzenamt geld diese leute
heim dienst organisation ist der
wichtigsten in den usa nahm ich eine
habe ich angst in dieser dramatischen
konstellation eine agentur oder eine
sensation sie eben die einen ihrer top
agenten gegen sich gewendet sieht
besteht diesjährige im wesentlichen die
bourne filme haben eine besonderheit
vielleicht auch insofern als irgend so
ein bisschen alte schule noch sind das
interessante ist aber dass das und das
war von anfang an dass auch eine große
rolle gespielt
zusammen gedacht wird mit dem zeitung
technologien mit einer seite zu tun hat
und es ist natürlich unter diesen
umständen sehr viel schwieriger als sich
davonzumachen dieser jason bohren kann
das aber für eine sehr interessante
weise und so haben diese bohren filme im
lauf der jahre uns auch ein bisschen so
vertraut gemacht eben mit den
überwachungstechniken
wir wurden gerade gehackt könnte
schlimmer sein als bei snowden die
gesichtserkennung meldet ein treffer oh
mein gott das ist jason bourne und
tauchte jetzt wieder auf es geht auch
hier wieder sehr stark geben darum das
ganze auf einer sehr interessanten sehr
dynamischen action ebene eben
durchzuziehen
das hat auch damit zu tun dass der
regisseur der jetzt zurückgekehrt ist
zudem freuen sich darauf spezialisiert
hat so ein bisschen das handwerk des
actionkinos auf eine sehr gute
altmodische weise zu bewahren
paul greengrass ist ein insgesamt für
mich einer der interessantesten
regisseure in diesem feld im moment im
amerikanischen kino
weiter wollen die gruppen institutionen
stürzen die gesellschaft kontrollieren
ich bin nicht auf deiner seite
und er zeichnet eben in den neuen film
auch wieder dass er jemand ist der
action auf eine weise inszenieren kann
die eben tatsächlich noch alles ins bild
bringt das in den stärker digital
bearbeiteten neuer einen großen
blockbuster filmen oft sehr stark auch
so ins ungefähre von verlusten
und wenn man das alles zusammen erzählt
würde ich sagen dass sie sich auf jeden
fall um einen sehenswerten film handelt
er ist tatsächlich im besten sinne
altmodisches actionkino verbunden mit
neueren politischen inhalten und wir
haben wer sich auf so etwas verstehen
oder werden so etwas interesse hat wird
sicher zufrieden sein mit diesem film